since everyone was self isolated in
quarantine money started Gardens to pass
the time but now is summer kicks off
some of those plants might take a hit
Bianca Holman shares a few tips to
maintain your garden this summer over
the past two months many across the
valley picked up new hobbies like
gardening as temperatures rise there are
things to keep in mind to protect your
garden we spoke with the experts here at
University of Nevada Cooperative
Extension Research Center and
demonstration orchard about desert
conditions on various fruits and
vegetables even if they hate the heat
like tomatoes we grew four varieties of
tomatoes and we found that for all four
varieties the 30% shade not touching the
plants we had terrific results while
green veggies like broccoli spinach and
cabbage favored winter months pumpkins
squash cantaloupe and even sweet
potatoes are ideal for summers long days
in triple-digit temperatures just as
long as they get enough water you can be
planting pumpkins and if you plant them
right this minute you might have
pumpkins in time for Halloween
specialists don't just study gardening
for science but it's also a service to
the community folks can become master
gardeners and we're not trying to sell
anything my job and the job of all the
volunteers for the whole goal is to
bring the best information we can to the
people of our area those interested can
also help tend to the garden as
volunteers like and Kasey trimming
grapes weeding planting seeds harvesting
right now there's a lot of harvesting
going on listen TLC you can just walk to
your backyard for your next meal plants
will really grow as long as they get
just a little bit of attention as long
as you make sure that you're growing
things that have a chance here reporting
from Decatur Boulevard in horse Road
Bianca Holman 8 News now